[Musique]
merci,
il est impossible d'aimer rencontrer
des infirmières pour nos
Sud-Coréens mais dans le drame, ils
tombent tous amoureux et
se rencontrent en Suisse et cela signifie beaucoup.
[Musique]
eh bien, je pense que c'est l'un des plus  des
pièces de théâtre romantiques dans le monde, c'est pourquoi
je suis venu aussi, donc je pense que les
cinéastes coréens font un très bon
choix en sélectionnant cet endroit et puis,
d'une manière ou d'une autre, vous avez cette serviette pour devenir
plus populaire dans le monde,
ok,
la série est devenue très  populaire
et l'endroit aussi, donc nous avons maintenant
de nombreux visiteurs qui viennent prendre une photo
de cet endroit précis, mais cela a été
assez écrasant de voir autant de
touristes venir si soudainement et aussi
venir pour une très courte visite,
merci
[Applaudissements]
non, c'est  comme le paradis sur Terre ouais mais
nous voulons vraiment essayer de
garder ça comme ça, c'est ce que
nous essayons de réaliser
oh
étranger
[Musique]